it's to france now that country has set
another record for daily covert 19 cases
with more than
16 000 new confirmed infections over the
last 24 hours and the number of people
hospitalized well that has risen as well
to contain the virus francis introduced
stricter rules in major cities including
marseille we'll talk with
corona researcher john campbell about a
possible second wave
after this from marseille residents in
marseille
enjoying what could be the last drink at
their local cafe for a while
from saturday bars and restaurants in
france's second largest city
will be forced to close for at least 15
days as the new coronavirus measures
come into place
owners and employees are in dismay this
restaurant manager says he has already
lost 200 000 euros since the beginning
of the year
we've taken out loans and it's not just
us it's the restaurants the shopkeepers
they all got loans we have to pay them
back in less than six months
or we will have to close down it's scary
marseille is on maximum alert due to a
surge in covet-19 cases
but many bar and restaurant workers feel
they are being unfairly targeted
we are unjustly punished stigmatized
fingers are automatically being pointed
at us
bars and restaurants we are responsible
for the rising covet cases in marseilles
it's nonsense how and why are we
responsible for this when we do
everything to comply with the rules
if people don't party or don't go out to
bars they will do it at home
i don't really see the difference
between a bar and someone's home
around the country other cities are also
bracing for tougher restrictions
in the capital paris buzzing restaurants
will have to shut at 10 pm
french health authorities have defended
the new measures
saying they are the only way to prevent
hospitals from becoming overburdened
we're joined now by john campbell one of
youtube's more famous chronovirus
researchers
and analysts many of us have been
following him since the pandemic
began thanks so much for coming in john
is the spike
we're seeing in marseille and and other
european
uh big cities is it a regional
phenomenon or
is this europe wide it's pretty well
europe wide i mean at the moment
spain is leading the increase in cases
then france and then the uk is
increasing quite a bit now
but there are notable exceptions like
italy so it is a bit patchy but
there was a summary by washington state
university in seattle just a couple of
days ago and they described europe as
surging generally
so we're seeing a general trend in
europe increases
but we are seeing particular countries
increasing at a more rapid rate
and of course what we need to do is
learn from the mistakes of the countries
that are increasing at a more rapid rate
and try and use that information to keep
the levels of spread down in other
countries
such as germany and the uk where the
levels are currently lower
a lot of people are talking about a
second wave being a possibility we need
to define our terms of course um
is this the second wave the start of one
it really depends on how you define it i
mean what really matters is the
pragmatic definition
and in the second wave or in increasing
cases
the point is we have a sustained
increase in cases from day to day from
week to week
and that is exactly what we're seeing in
parts of europe and and
we're seeing it at different levels as
well so as we've said spain
and france at higher levels uk and
germany still increasing
albeit at lower levels i probably would
call it a second wave personally because
obviously quite high numbers of cases
back in march
april may then we went down in the
summer there's a lot of reasons for that
and now we're going back up again but i
really think it's important to learn
some of the lessons from these other
countries that are that are um
doing well in the countries that aren't
doing so aren't doing so well at the
moment
okay what would be some of those lessons
if you if you would john
well it italy did very well italy's app
is working very well we only had started
with the app yesterday in the uk which
is really quite
a sad situation that has taken so well
and italy wasn't complacent over the
summer
because italy suffered so badly in the
first wave and it was the first country
really to suffer
that i don't think it had forgotten the
lessons of the of what we might call
this first wave
whereas other countries took their foot
off the off the accelerator a little bit
italy maintained its 14 days quarantine
it didn't really encourage tourism the
way spain did
a lot of the resurgencing cases in spain
now from tourism
so it was minimal and italy used its
testing capacity
wisely so all countries have limited
testing capacity
but italy targeted to test trace and
isolate the contacts of people that were
symptomatic
the contacts of people that were
asymptomatic whether it's work family or
social
and the other thing they did in italy
was they identified specific infection
drivers and one of those was dancing in
nightclubs
so that was banned on the 17th that's
that's the
aerosols that are probably responsible
there but we have time for one more
question
uh um what about um the
mutation uh some people have been saying
is is how dangerous is that what's
happening with the mutation
the th there's an ongoing debate about
this and
this virus mutates all the time we know
it mutates all the time
but the consensus of scientific opinion
in the uk at the moment
is that although the virus is mutating
and although this is useful for what we
call phylogenetic analysis
we can work out where a particular viral
strain came from by
tracing back the mutations the consensus
of opinion is
at the moment this is not dramatically
increasing
or reducing how transmissible the virus
is or the pathogenicity of the virus
how likely the virus is to cause severe
disease but that's always a possibility
it could happen
and so for nothing for now already but
the consensus opinion for now john we'll
take that as good
okay john campbell that's right john
campbell thanks so much for coming in
and
keep up your work there for all of us
thanks very much pleasure
let's get you around up now some of the
other developments in the pandemic
israel has toughened its coronavirus
measures after a second lockdown failed
to reduce new infections the new rules
will close most workplaces shutter
markets and further limit prayers
and demonstrations britain has reported
its highest number of new cases in a day
just over
6 600. the government announcing
sweeping new measures earlier in the
week designed to curb the spread of the
virus and the number of people who have
died from covet in mexico
has now passed 75 000. that country has
seen more than
715 000 infections
and rio de janeiro has delayed next
year's world famous carnival
celebrations the event which draws
millions of visitors was to take place
in february but has been postponed
indefinitely
due to the pandemic brazil's grappling
with the world's second deadliest
outbreak
you